hallo ihr drei ich binston Fanatic oder
okay kennen mich aus blogtv und ich habe
drei Fragen an euch jeder von euch
kannine Frage beantworten ist egal W die
erste Frage ist warum ti die kannst du
mir beantworten warum spielst du
eigentlich immer die Frau okay ich meine
es gibt ja noch pH und II aber warum
spielst du ausgerechnet immer die Frau
würde mich wirklich interessieren ich
glaub das ist die nervigste Frage die
wieder gestellt wird ja stimmt die Frage
kommt echt recht oft aber ich werde sie
dir beantworten
ähm warum ich immer die Frau spiele ja
wir haben einfach uns mal entschlossen
dass ich die Frau Spiele und hat sich
halt immer angeboten jetzt und weil tit
ist ja nicht dafür auch bekannt dass ich
immer die Frau Spiele und ich glaube das
ist auch ganz gut wenn man bei einer
Person bleibt wo man sagt hey die
verkörpert die und die Frau das finde
ich eigentlich ganz gut drum bin ich die
Frau
öfter die zweite
Frage hattet ihr schon mal daran gedacht
W Titi aufzulösen also hatt ihr euch
schon mal soweit gestritten dass ihr
dachtet nee lösen wir jetzt he TT auf
und habt euch das dann noch mal
umüberlegt also ja die zweite Frage war
ja hier ob wir uns mal überlegt haben WT
aufzulösen
wüsste ich jetzt nicht also es gab
sicher mal Momente an den man halt sagt
das istes gerade so stressig und oder
wenn es mal nicht gut läuft wenn man
viel Hoffnung irgendwie in Video steckt
und es kommt absolut nicht gut an dann
denkt man
sich was ist das warum machen wir uns
jetzt die ganze Mühe umsonst und
dann ja aber auflösen kommt glaube ich
nicht in Frage
nie die dritte Frage ist HST also
persönlich zu Phil Phil findest du das
nicht peinlich bei Bisam der Besen mit
dem Staubsauger da die Szene da also ich
finde das irgendwie Lust alle meine
Freunde haben sich kaputt gelacht aber
finde du das einfach nicht peinlich
irgendwie würde mich freuen wenn ihr
antworten würdet und ich habe es dann
weiterhin auf Blog TV und viel Spaß noch
und viel Erfolg mit euren Videos genau
du hast gefragt wegen bessem der Besen
warum ich dort
ähm ja mit dem Staubsauger Oralverkehr
betreibe aber du vergisst das war nicht
ich das war Jack und was ich damit sagen
will ist eigentlich man muss immer
trennen was was deine Rolle ist und wer
du bist und das war wirklich ein Sketch
von uns und da habe ich jemanden
gespielt und dann ist mir auch wirklich
nichts peinlich also wenn wir in der
Rolle sind dann können wir alles machen
auch als Gangster mit 5 XL rosa T-Shirt
im E-Center die Leute fragen welcher
Wein gut ist
z.B